- [Voiceover] The polynomial expression,
36 y to the third minus
100y can be factored as
4y times all of this,
My plus g, times My minus g,
where M and g are integers.
Sally wrote that g could be equal to 3.
Brandon wrote that g could be equal to 10.
Which student is correct?
Now, when you look at this,
it seems really daunting,
all this M's and g's here,
but we just need to realize
that they're factoring out,
first they factored out a
4y from the 36y to the third
minus 100y, and it looks
like whatever's left
is a difference of squares,
which they then factor
even further.
So I encourage you to pause
the video and just factor
this out as much as you can.
First factoring out a 4y,
and then we can think
about what g is going to be
equal to, or whether Sally
or Brandon is correct.
So, then now let's work
through this together.
So, if we look at,
if we look at this
expression right over here,
we want to factor out a 4y,
so 36y to the third
minus 100y,
that's the same thing as,
36y to the third is the same thing as 4y
times, let's see,
4y times 9y squared,
right?
Because 4 times 9 is 36,
and y times y squared is y to the third,
so all I did to get the
9y squared is I divided
36 by 4 to get the 9, and
I divided y to the third
by the y to get y squared,
so if you factor out a 4y,
you're left with 9y squared
for that first term, and then,
for the second term, let's see,
if we, we're going to subtract,
if we factor out a 4y again,
what's left over?
100 divided by 4 is 25,
and then y divided by y
is just 1, so we're left with a 25 here.
So just to be clear what's going on,
this 36y to the third,
I just rewrote it as 4y times 9y squared.
One way to think about it
is I wrote it with the 4y
factored out, and then,
the 100y, right over here,
I wrote it with the 4y factored out,
so it's 4y times 25,
and now it's very clear
that we can factor out 4y
from this entire thing,
so we can factor out,
you can think of it as
undistributing the 4y,
so this is going to be equal to
4y and what is left over?
Well, if you factor out a
4y out of this first term,
you're going to have a 9y squared,
9y squared, and then minus 25,
and then we're going to
be left with minus 25,
and when we write it like this,
we see what we have in parentheses here.
This is a difference of squares, and,
we could skip a step, but
let me just rewrite it,
so we could rewrite it as, literally,
a difference of squares.
9y squared, that is the same thing as,
that is the same thing as
3y, that whole thing to the 2nd power,
3 squared is 9, y squared is y squared,
and then we have
minus 25, we can rewrite as 5 squared,
so you see, we have a
difference of squares,
and we've seen this
pattern multiple times.
If this is the first time you're
seeing it, I encourage you
to watch the videos on Khan Academy
on difference of squares, but
we know anything of the form,
anything of the form a
squared minus b squared,
let me do it in that color,
minus b squared can be
factored as being equal to,
this is equal to, if I were
to write it as a product
of two binomials,
this is going to be equal to
a plus b
times a minus b,
and you can verify that that works,
if you've never seen this before,
or you can watch those videos for review.
So this right over here
can be rewritten as
4y, which we factored
out at the beginning,
it's going to be times the
product of two binomials
for this part right over here,
and so in this case, a is 3y,
so it's going to be 3y
plus 5, times 3y minus 5,
so let me write that down.
So 3y plus 5
times 3y minus 5.
3y minus 5.
So now that we factored
this, let's go back to what
they originally told
us, so then we have 4y,
so this 4y corresponds to
that 4y, right over there,
and then you have My plus g,
and then you have My minus g,
so you could view the My,
the My's right over there,
that's the 3y right over there,
so we could say that M is equal to 3,
M is equal to 3,
and then we do plus 5 and minus 5,
plus g and minus g, so,
g, if we're pattern
matching right over here,
g is going to be equal to 5.
So g is equal to 5.
So what's interesting about this problem
is that neither one of them
are correct, so, I could write,
neither is correct.
G is equal to 5.
That was a tricky one.